CELINE: I'm Celine.
I'm thrilled to be here with
Loree, a pioneer in our midst.
So why don't I just kick it off.
The format will be, I'll have a
couple of questions for Loree,
and then we'll open it up to any
questions you guys might have.
So think about those, and
we'll open up to you guys
probably 10, 15 minutes
before the end of the event.
OK.
So, hi, Loree.
LOREE DRAUDE: Hi, Celine.
CELINE: So, let's kick it off.
And can you just give
us a brief background
of what took you to the
Navy and how you ended up
on that groundbreaking
deployment.
LOREE DRAUDE: Sure.
Well, in some ways, I like
to say that it's genetic.
Both my parents were
in the military.
My dad was a career
Marine Corps officer,
and my mom was in the
Marines for a year.
She and my dad married.
She got pregnant with me.
And back then, if you
were a woman officer,
you had to get out of the
military when you got pregnant.
So I kind of ended my
mom's military career.
But I think growing
up in the Marine Corp,
there were just certain
values that were imbued in me,
that there was an expectation
that I would somehow
serve my country.
And I was very used to
the military environment.
I grew up with two brothers.
I'm the oldest of three.
So I was very used to being
in a military environment
and being comfortable
around my brothers.
So when it came
time for college,
I wasn't really sure
what I wanted to do.
At that time, I had no
idea about aviation.
My dad was an infantry
officer, which
means he's boots on the ground.
And any time he ever
talked about aviators,
it was typically what
slackers they are.
So I didn't really have
a favorable impression
of aviation at that
point, and I had no idea
that women could do it.
So I went off to college
at University of San Diego
and started Navy ROTC there.
And while I was there, I went on
a field trip my freshman year.
And San Diego, huge military
base, especially Navy.
So we went to Miramar.
we went to El Toro,
to Tustin, all of
these military bases,
and it was an
aviation-themed field trip.
And I met a bunch of aviators.
And what impressed
me was that they
were so passionate
about what they did,
and they were really funny.
There's some combination
of humor and passion
that just really appealed to me.
And I think I had made
some comment about, oh,
this looks like
such a great job.
I wish I could do it.
And they were like,
oh, well actually,
there are some female pilots
who are instructor pilots.
So they go through
the training syllabus
and then they
become instructors,
or they're combat
support pilots, which
means you don't actually go
out and fly a combat mission,
but you train
other combat pilots
on how to do their mission.
And I thought, wow.
Cool.
OK, I can live with that.
That sounds really interesting.
So I applied to flight school
and went to flight school
after I got my commission
and graduated from college.
So in flight school,
my expectation
was that I was going to
become either an instructor
pilot or a combat
support pilot, and that's
indeed what happened.
I became a support
pilot in F-18 Hornets.
So what I would do is
I would fly in an F-18,
and I would pretend
to be a missile.
I'd go really fast, and
ships and other aircraft
would practice tracking me.
So in that way I
was training them.
But I got to fly an F-18,
which was really amazing.
It's just an incredible
piece of machinery,
and I felt very lucky
to be able to do that.
But when I had gone
through my training,
before I ever went to F-18s, I
did do carrier qualifications
in the training jet.
And actually, my training was
exactly the same as all the men
that were going
through up to the point
to when we selected
what we were going
to after finishing
that training.
Then they would
go to combat jets,
and I would go to
a support squadron.
So I remember thinking
during the training
while we were out
on the carrier and I
had done my first landings
in this training jet, wow.
This is amazing.
This looks like
an incredible job,
and again, I'm really
bummed I can't do this
because women aren't allowed
to fly in combat jets.
But this is really neat.
So when the law
did change in '93
and that option
became available,
I was very excited to become
part of that and to deploy.
And I ended up doing
two deployments.
The reason I wrote the book was
because of my first deployment.
It was the first one that
had women on the West Coast,
and we had a lot of challenges.
And when we got back from
that first appointment,
there were some news stories.
Some of the women who in
my air wing-- I'll explain.
An air wing is the larger group
of all the various squadrons
on an aircraft carrier,
typically about 10 squadrons.
So you have the F-18 squadrons,
you have the Tomcat squadrons,
you have the E-2, the one
with the Frisbee on top
that does early warning.
And in the air wing, we
had had about 20 women,
and a few of them had had
some pretty bad experiences
and went to the
media and claimed
that they had been
discriminated against.
And so I had had a pretty
positive experience,
and I didn't feel
like that really
represented my experience
in the military.
I certainly had encountered
some challenges as well,
but I guess I wanted to
tell my story about how
the deployment had gone for me.
And so that's why
I wrote the book.
CELINE: Great.
So your deployment started
off with a bit of a tragedy.
Can you share with
us what happened
and how that might
have set the tone?
LOREE DRAUDE: Sure.
So the very first day I went
out to the "Abraham Lincoln,"
which was the carrier
that I was assigned to.
I flew out with my crew, and
this was the training period
before we go out on a
six-month deployment.
We call it work-ups
because you're working up
to go out on the real deal,
out to the Persian Gulf.
And so we were off the
coast of California,
and I flew out with my crew.
And it was a gorgeous
San Diego day.
And we were in the holding
pattern, which typically
is about 20 miles
south of the ship.
And so I'm on a radio
frequency that all
of the planes that
are approaching
are on, which is separate
from the tower frequency.
The tower frequency is the
one that the airplanes who
are at the carrier practice
doing their landings
and takeoffs, so they're
on a separate frequency.
So we were just
hanging out, waiting
to get called to come
approach the carrier
and do our landings.
And it was taking a long time.
And even some of
the guys in my jet
who had been on deployments
before and training before
were like, I don't
know what's going on.
We just figured, oh, we're new.
They're figuring
out how to do this.
So we ended up going.
I did my landings, and
then, since we were still
doing work-ups, we
flew back to San Diego,
and later found out
that the reason that we
were on holding for so long was
because a Tomcat had crashed
right when we had arrived
in the holding pattern.
And we had no idea
until we got back.
I read in the newspaper the next
morning that what had happened
was the Tomcat had
been coming in to land,
had an engine failure.
The jet crashed.
The pilot in the front
seat had ejected.
They had been lost
at sea, and they
had withheld the name pending
notifying his next of kin.
The RIO had been ejected
and was out safely.
And so I was slightly relieved
because I didn't really
know any the male
pilots at the squadron.
But I knew all the women.
There were three women in that
squadron, two pilots and one
RIO, which stands for
Radar Intercept Officer.
Sorry.
There's so many acronyms in
the Navy, just like Google.
So it turned out that that
pilot was Kara Hultgreen,
and she had died during
this landing approach.
And so I didn't find out
until I had come back
to the ship the next day.
And it was, obviously,
devastating to lose a friend.
But also, this is the very
beginning of our work-ups.
The women had just really
started showing up on the ship.
And there were already
some grumblings among some
of the men on the
ship, especially
in some of the fighter
squadrons, which
tend to be very macho, not so
accepting of, I think, change.
So that really set a really
tough tone for our deployment.
There were questions
about her qualifications
almost immediately.
And in all the years
that I had served,
I had never ever seen
people question--
when a male aviator had a crash,
they would never question,
or people wouldn't release
his training records
to the public, which
happened with Kara.
So that just added to
the stress, for sure.
CELINE: You said you had a
relatively positive experience,
but have you ever
felt discriminated
against for being a
woman in the Navy?
LOREE DRAUDE: Yeah.
I mean, there are definitely
a lot of situations
that I found myself in.
And really, depending
on the situation,
I think that determined
my course of action.
So there's certain battles
that are worth fighting,
and there are certain
battles that you just let go.
So I think there's a difference
between discrimination
and hostile
environment, and there
are a lot of hostile
environments in the Navy.
Just places where--
CELINE: Tell us about an example
of a hostile environment.
LOREE DRAUDE: So one time
we did a training detachment
to El Centro,
California, which is
kind of in the
middle of nowhere,
and training squadrons come
through there regularly.
And so the squadron
before us had left up
a poster in the ready room.
And the ready room is where
all the pilots hang out
waiting to go do their flights.
And it was this poster of
three very well-endowed women
with very little on, and
it said something like,
to the studs of VT-22,
whatever the squadron is,
we love you guys, or
something like that.
And so we walked in,
and everyone kind of
laughed at the poster.
And I was like, OK.
And then I expected the next
day that it would be taken down.
Well, no one took it down.
And so I'm like, OK.
I'm going to have a
little fun with this.
So I went and bought a Playgirl
and got the centerfold.
And I think I made a drawing
of the bombs that we carry,
and I just cut that out and put
it on the-- covered up the guy
and put that up on the wall,
and wrote something like,
to the hot babe--
because I was the only
female student-- of VT-23.
Hope you can get your bomb on
target, or something like that.
It was funny.
We joked about
that kind of stuff.
I felt like when I was going
through the training command,
it was like going through
with a lot of brothers.
I mean, at that
time, I was not going
to be assigned to a combat jet.
So I don't know.
I was maybe this
curiosity going through.
The other thing, too, is
that my executive officer
in my training squad was African
American and a Tomcat pilot,
and that's extremely rare.
There just were not a
lot of minority pilots.
And so I think he really
looked out for me a lot.
And having a mentor like that
and an advocate really helped.
Anyway, the funny thing
was that some of the guys
were like, that's so gross.
And I'm like, yeah.
Have a little appreciation here.
And we took both posters
down and laughed about it.
That wasn't so bad, and
we joked about that.
I had a really tough time
going through the F-18 Hornet
training squadron.
And I think a lot
of that was timing.
It was right after Tailhook '91.
And if you know anything
about Tailhook '91--
CELINE: Tell us about that.
LOREE DRAUDE: OK.
It was a big controversy
for the Navy.
They have an annual convention
every year in Las Vegas--
they used to until Tailhook '91.
And it's like a big reunion.
And Naval aviators, Marine
Corps aviators from all
over get together, and
it's your one chance
to catch back up with
all your friends.
Defense contractors come
in and give you swag.
I mean, it's just a big party.
And so the year I went,
I was still a student.
Before I went, my squadron mates
had told me, don't go here.
Don't go here.
These are bad areas.
Bad things happen.
Just stay away from them.
And the "theres" were the third
floor of the Las Vegas Hilton.
And it tended to be this
really crowded party
environment with a lot
alcohol, and people
would do pretty
inappropriate things.
And so the year that
I went, the only year
that I went to Tailhook,
there was a female officer
who was assaulted.
There were several women
who had gotten assaulted.
And so there was this big
investigation that happened.
This was also right at the
end of the first Gulf War.
So a lot of aviators were
coming back pretty pumped up,
and people were also
starting to talk
about opening roles for women.
And so there was a
lot of commentary
during some of the sessions
about women flying in combat
and a lot of negative
reactions from the men.
So all of this came together.
Some very wrong things
happened, and then
the investigation by the
Navy was very hard-handed.
It just was a really challenging
time to be in the military.
So then I go to this
F-18 training squadron,
where at first, I
was the only woman.
There was another woman
that came through after me.
But they just were
not happy about having
a woman come through.
And I wasn't going
to a combat squadron.
The law had not
changed by that point.
But I definitely did
not feel welcome.
And I think if Tailhook
had not just happened,
I don't think it
would've been the same.
I really felt like that set the
stage for what happened there.
So at that squadron,
someone else
had posted up an article on a
board about why women shouldn't
be allowed to fly in combat.
And I'm the only
female student there,
so it's like, now what do I do?
I wasn't sure if I
should say something
or if I should just let it go.
And I thought back to how
I had handled the pin-up.
So I found this letter to the
editor that was really funny.
It was written by a man who
had just outrageous things
about why women should not
be allowed to fly in combat--
things like, if they
pull G's, you know,
it's going to rip
their uterus out.
Just really stupid
stuff like that.
And I thought, OK, I'm going
to one-up you, essentially.
And that did not go
over well at all.
It turned out-- the
pin-up was funny.
This did not go over well.
I think part of it
was the person who
had put that article up
was the executive officer
of the squadron, which is
like the second in command.
So having leadership essentially
saying we don't really want you
here, it was tough
to deal with that.
And then he took his down
and put mine up, and said,
this is from Lieutenant Draude.
So then the instructor
started saying
that I had made
him take his down.
And it just turned
into this big mess.
And so what was already really
challenging and difficult just
became really bad.
So I barely made it
through that squadron.
And that, I think, was
a real shock for me
because I never had
really felt like I
had experienced discrimination.
College, in my Navy ROTC
unit, even in flight school
I felt very supported
along the way.
But in that squadron, that
was really the first time.
CELINE: So based on
experiences like that,
what have you learned as far
as when to fight the system,
when to play within the
rules, when to let things go?
What's some advice
that you would have?
LOREE DRAUDE: It's a tough call.
I mean, I think back
to that and wonder, OK,
if I could do it all
over again, would I
have done something differently?
Well, the woman who came in
behind me was very quiet.
She would not engage
like that at all,
and she made it through.
I think what I'd
recommend is you really
have to assess the situation
and know whether or not
this is an environment where
you can engage like that,
and if people are going
to appreciate that,
or if they're going to
really take it the wrong way
or not appreciate the
effort that you're making.
I think in the first
example with the pin-up,
I was with a bunch of
aviators that were my friends,
and it wasn't as big of a deal.
In the second,
there was definitely
a situation where these
instructor pilots were feeling
like they were being forced
to change and do something
that they really
didn't want to do.
And I don't know that
there was anything
I could have done to
really have been successful
in that situation.
So then, when the
law did change and it
was time for me
to either go back
to that squadron or transition
to another aircraft,
I did not go back
to that squadron.
They did not want me to
come back through there,
and I could have fought it.
So that was a choice
where I was deciding,
do I want to fight
for this, or do I
want to go deploy
and be part of this?
And that was a decision
where I said, you know what?
This battle's not
worth fighting.
I think I'm going to do more
for women in the military
by deploying with
a squadron that's
going to support me and
give me the opportunity
to be successful
and to do my job,
rather than keep fighting to
be in a community that really
doesn't want me in it.
CELINE: Great.
In the book, you
mention several times
where you've modified
your behavior a little bit
to kind of fit in.
Can you give us--
you've given us
a few examples, but
another example of that,
and how you decide when
and how to do that?
LOREE DRAUDE: I think being
on the aircraft carrier,
I slightly modified my
behavior in that I really
tried to think
about what it must
be like for all these
men in the Navy,
on the ship, that are used to
being in the Navy on a ship
altogether, not
having women around,
not having to, I don't know--
CELINE: --be
politically correct.
LOREE DRAUDE: Yes, exactly.
Or be polite, or
even-- so I tried
to think, what would it
be like for them to then
have this big change
thrust upon them,
and what are their expectations?
And I think being
empathetic to that helped.
And so when I was on the
ship, I didn't wear makeup.
I never wore perfume.
I'm never going to be
mistaken for a man.
I'm definitely a woman.
So I don't want to
really force it on them
even more, if that makes sense.
And I think being in the ready
room, in that environment,
it is a very rough and
joking environment.
People are always giving
each other a hard time.
But it's all done typically
in a sense of bonding,
with the sense of
bonding where you're
kind of joking around
with each other.
CELINE: In the book,
you also talk about,
at times, being
disappointed at some
of the behavior of
the other women.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that,
if you still feel that way?
LOREE DRAUDE: Yeah.
For example, not wearing
makeup and having
my hair tucked into
my flight suit,
things like that that I
thought were professional.
There were some women who were
like, look, I'm going to be me,
and I don't care.
And they'd wear red
fingernail polish.
They'd have their hair flying.
But for me, it was a
matter of professionalism.
I mean, now, looking back,
I'm definitely more, I think,
tolerant.
Back then I was like, oh,
we have to be very uniform
and follow the
rules and all that.
But I think now I am definitely
more relaxed about it.
And as far as behaviors
and things like that,
one big thing that comes up
a lot is dating on the ship.
And again, it's a very
contained environment.
And having
relationships like that
are detrimental in my opinion,
because it just takes the focus
off what we're doing.
CELINE: So talk about the high
expectations and the pressure.
How did you personally
deal with that?
I think Neil alluded to not only
are you getting this extremely
risky, challenging
job, but you're
doing it with all 8,000
eyes looking at you.
LOREE DRAUDE: I had
a great squadron.
I mean, I was very fortunate.
The people in my squadron
were just great people.
I think they appreciated
the stress that I was under,
and they were just
always supportive of me.
I joked-- I wrote in the book
one time about how I had one
really bad night where
I was trying to land.
Three times I came in
to land, and each time I
had vultured, which means when
you hit the deck, the hook
either bounces-- or that's
the excuse you like to say.
It was a mechanical failure.
But really I put
too much power on.
It landed too long.
The hook [INAUDIBLE] the wire,
so it doesn't grab the wire
and you go flying again.
We got back.
Finally, I landed
on the fourth time.
It was humiliating, because like
Neil said, everyone's watching.
This is like everyone gets
popcorn and sits down and is
watching the landings.
And I was just like,
I'm just embarrassing.
I'm embarrassing my squadron.
I'm embarrassing women.
There was a lot of pressure
I was putting on myself.
But we get out of the
jet and one of the guys
was like, hey, thanks for
the extra flight time.
They were always trying
to find the positive.
And so that was really helpful,
feeling like I was supported.
CELINE: That's great.
And what do you think was
different about that squadron
than the other
squadron where you
had the hostile environment?
Was it the leadership?
Just the people?
A culture?
LOREE DRAUDE: It's
definitely the leadership.
I can't emphasize that enough.
There were fighter
squadrons in our airway,
and some of my
friends were-- well,
I had female pilot friends
in some of those squadrons,
and it was really
challenging for them.
And I think it's because the
leaders in those squadrons,
their attitude was, OK.
We're being forced to
take these women with us.
Let's just get through it.
And some of them,
they adopted what
they called a gender
neutral policy, which
meant that you can't give
anybody special treatment.
They were so afraid of being
perceived as giving women
special treatment
that, if anything,
they didn't give the people
who needed help enough help.
And so I was very lucky that
I had a commanding officer who
would stand up for all the
people in his squadron.
And I never felt like he
was standing up more for me
because I was a woman.
I just felt like all the junior
officers in that squadron
can count on him.
When we had bad landings or did
something stupid on the flight
deck, the officer who's
in charge of all that
is called the air boss, and
he sits up there in the tower
and is watching over everything
happening on the deck.
And he'll say, OK, who's
the pilot in that jet?
I want to see him or her.
And my commanding
officer's policy
was he was the one who was
going to go up and catch
flak for whatever we had done.
And then he'd come back
and tell us, OK, here's
what you could do better.
So he was a great leader.
And even in my squadron,
there were actually--
I was surprised
later to find out
that a lot of the
men in my squadron
were not happy about the change,
about having women integrated.
But they were so
professional that they
put their personal feelings
aside and figured out, OK,
we're going to make this work.
CELINE: That's great
So for the civilians
in the audience
like myself, can you
tell us a little bit more
what life on a ship is like?
What's the hardest
part about it?
What is something that
we wouldn't imagine?
LOREE DRAUDE: It's a really
unique environment, obviously.
I think for aviators, it's
very different than the rest
of the ship's crew.
We're very lucky.
As aviators, we get to leave
the ship for a few hours,
go fly, and then come back.
Living on the carrier is
challenging because everything
is contained, and if there's
something you need and it's not
on the ship, then
you're out of luck.
And when I went through
my first deployment,
we didn't even have email.
So the only contact we really
had with the outside world
was if you got mail,
that got delivered,
or if you got a phone card,
you could call back home.
But people couldn't call you.
So I think the most
difficult thing was just
feeling so disconnected
from the rest of the world
sometimes and wondering if
anyone back home is thinking
about you or caring
what's going on.
So that's tough.
After being out at sea for
awhile, the food is horrible.
It's so bad.
And I was a vegetarian
on my second deployment,
which is insane.
My squadron mates,
they'd joke with me.
They were like, are you taking
a POW correspondence course?
Why are you eating this?
So when we'd go pull into
port every three weeks or so
and go on liberty, we'd always
go to a really nice restaurant.
CELINE: Very nice.
With that, I'm
conscious of time.
I want to open up to
anyone in the audience
for some questions for Loree.
AUDIENCE: Can you
share how you've
translated some of
those experiences
into civilian and your
professional life today?
LOREE DRAUDE: I think being
in an environment that
is new and different and
understanding that everybody's
got their own things going
on, their own issues,
and getting to know people more.
That, for me, I
think, is an effect
of growing up in so
many different places.
And I think that's one of the
reasons why the military was
a good fit for
me, was that I was
used to working with a lot
of different types of people.
And in the civilian world,
making the transition to that,
I think having worked in
a resource-constrained
environment in the
military and being
able to identify with
different people,
I think that's been helpful.
I also think that even
though the military trains
us to be very specific
about how we react
to different
situations, there are so
many things that happen
where they're ambiguous.
You're just like, well, OK.
This isn't in my checklist.
I don't have the emergency
procedure checklist for this.
But the military
training is so solid
that it does enable
you to, I think,
trust your instincts
and your gut,
and leverage that
to make a decision.
So I would say
just the experience
I had dealing with
resource-constrained
environments, a lot of
different types of people
with different backgrounds,
different attitudes,
and really trying to connect
with them on a level somehow,
that's been helpful.
AUDIENCE: In this
job and other jobs,
was your experience
that as a vet,
you were sort of put
to the top of the list?
Or was it something
different, where as a vet,
you were considered to be
maybe a risk of some sort?
LOREE DRAUDE: Yeah.
There are a lot of stereotypes
about veterans, good and bad.
And I think that every
person's unique, obviously.
I can recall people
in previous roles,
like when I worked in
management consulting,
someone made the comment--
we were looking at a review
board and a promotion
board, and someone made
the comment with me in the room,
knowing that I was a veteran,
you know, I don't normally
like to promote veterans.
They just typically
don't do well here.
And it's like, what?
It was kind of shocking.
Because I do think
that veterans bring
a lot of very positive skills
to the workplace, specifically
the business workplace.
I think a lot of challenges
that veterans have is just
translating their skills
and really understanding
that, even though the civilian
environment is different,
in a lot of ways, what
they've done in the military
is so relevant and applicable
to the civilian world.
And when I transitioned
15 years ago,
I can still remember
just how much anxiety
I had about that transition.
Because growing up
in the Marine Corps
and then being in the
Navy for 10 years,
the civilian world looked scary.
I mean, after my
experiences, I don't
know if I really
trust civilians.
It's just so different
than what I'm used to.
And so I think
now, looking back,
it's just so obvious to me.
And I've learned
to appreciate how
challenging it is for a
lot of people getting out,
having been through that myself.
So one of the things I just
really love about Google
is how much outreach
they're doing for veterans
and how much they're helping
them with that transition
and easing their fears,
but also really helping
to prepare them for how
to translate what they did
in the military to what they
might do in the civilian world.
Because there are a lot of
things that translate well,
but you just don't know how
to say it in civilian speak.
So we have to keep
helping the veterans
with how they can do that.
AUDIENCE: Did you ever feel
like there were instances
of discrimination or things
that maybe weren't big enough
to bring to your superiors,
but you kind of struggled with,
do I make a big deal
about this, or is this
going to cause more people
to be annoyed with me?
I don't know if you
can share an experience
like that or example.
You could probably
think of many.
LOREE DRAUDE: Yeah.
There are definitely many.
And I think any
time it happened,
I just had to think
of the circumstances.
What was this person-- there
were so many times when people
would say things where I really
don't believe that they meant
to be discriminatory, or
they just didn't really
realize the words coming
out of their mouth.
There were many times when the
guys that were in my squadron
would say something
really inappropriate,
and then they're
like, oh, sorry Loree.
We forgot that you were a woman.
And I'm like, OK.
I think that's a compliment.
So I would really think about
what the circumstances were.
When we go out to do
the carrier training,
that's the first time that
we officially get call signs.
Because you get a fun
patch for everything.
I have my jacket over there.
And there are a lot
of different patches
that we like to
have in the Navy.
And you get a name patch, and
you get your call sign on it.
So there was a list
up on the board
where people could go and write
call signs, your recommended
call signs for people.
And typically in the Navy,
Air Force, and Marine Corps
as well, your call sign is
either based on your last name
or on something stupid
that you've done.
And so I wasn't sure what
was going to go up there.
And so under my name, there
were some very typical
feminine things like Braids,
because I would braid my hair.
And I think Rowdy was up there
because it rhymed with Draude.
And someone had put Drano.
And I was like, Drano?
I don't get that.
And I asked some of
my fellow students,
and they looked uncomfortable.
I'm like, uh-oh.
OK, what does that mean?
And they're like, oh,
Drano, like a pipe cleaner.
I'm like, still not
getting you, because I
was raised Catholic School.
So I'm like, what?
And they're like, you
know, you give blow jobs.
I'm like, what?
I was so offended and pissed.
I was really shocked that
anyone would say that.
And I have no idea who wrote it.
So at that point,
it's like, first, I
have no idea how I'm going
to prove who wrote that.
And I'm like, the
guy is an asshole,
so I'm not going to
bother with this.
And so that was one example.
There are just a lot
of things like that
that happen where you just--
in that situation, I assessed,
OK, this is not going to
have wider implications.
Most of the guys around
me know that that's not
the type of person I
am, or I don't know,
that it's just not
really appropriate,
and that it wasn't going
to be worth fighting for.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious.
You mentioned
several areas where
there were discriminatory
practices, sometimes
unintentional, or
hostile work environment.
I'm curious if you've ever
seen anything, probably
on a much milder scale, here
at Google, either unconscious
bias, that kind of thing.
One Googler recently had a
very interesting post where she
shared her experiences about how
many of the off-sites and fun
events seem kind
of like "bro-y".
And [INAUDIBLE] in
[INAUDIBLE], so they
would go out drinking and stuff,
and she felt very left out.
LOREE DRAUDE: Yeah.
I've been at Google
for a year and a half,
and I've been really impressed
by the unconscious bias
training and the bias
busting workshops
that are following on from that.
I wish that the military
would do something like that.
Because there's plenty
of conscious bias
that happens, and
some people are still
very open about their feelings
about different issues.
I mean, I've never seen anything
like what happened in the Navy.
But I will say that
I think it's still
the case where just
the words that we use
and the language that we use
and even things like off-sites,
people aren't always as
inclusive or thoughtful
about some of those things.
And it's just natural.
I think that it's an evolution.
And the more diverse we
make our environment,
the more we have to be
thoughtful about those things.
In my org we have a
couple of Googlers
who have physical
challenges that
have to be incorporated
into our off-site plans.
And it's like, OK.
That's not a big deal.
I think it's just
something that if you
want to have an
inclusive culture
and hire the best
people, then you
need to make sure that you
are creating a culture where
all those types of people
are going to feel included.
It's funny though.
There are things
that seem really
small that still are a factor.
Even on my team,
I've been trying
not to say "hey
you guys" anymore.
Things that I grew up with that
now that I think about them,
it's like oh, yes.
That can make some
people feel excluded.
And even though I
think most people think
of it in the generic
sense, you're
talking about guys, not gals.
So there are just things
like that, words or language
that, I think, is part of how
we speak that we might want
to reconsider because it still
can sometimes feel exclusive.
AUDIENCE: You said you were
born into a military family,
and that you were
going into a field
where there's not much women.
And you experienced a lot
of hardships along the way.
Who did you confide in, and who
were your instrumental friends
and confidantes?
You mentioned that you
had a great mentor,
as well, who was
it your squadron.
And also, I wanted to find out
the second piece, which is,
I think you're a Googler?
I see a badge.
LOREE DRAUDE: I am.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What led you, then,
to also decide to leave?
LOREE DRAUDE: Yeah.
So when I was in
the Navy, my parents
were huge pillars of
support-- especially my dad
because he had a long
career in the military.
He knew what it was
like to lose people
that you had served with
much more than I did.
On my first deployment,
we lost like 11 people.
It was a lot for a deployment.
But as an infantry
officer in Vietnam,
he had dealt with that
on a much bigger basis.
So I think my parents
are definitely
a huge-- they were
amazing for support.
I had some friends, other
women that I had gone through
with that were on
the ship with me,
and they were also
great support.
We would get together
and share experiences
and commiserate sometimes, but
also help boost each other up.
My squadron was also amazing.
I had a couple of
different friends
in my squadron that got
beyond their personal biases
and were there to
help me be successful.
So I think that
really helped as well.
At the time, I was married.
So my husband was
also in the military,
and he could appreciate
what was happening.
And so just having that support
back home was also helpful.
So I had a really
good support network,
and I think that's
one of the things that
really helped me be successful.
The second part about
why did I get out
of the Navy, a couple
different things.
I reached the point where
my commitment was up.
So as a pilot, I had
to serve seven years
after I got my wings, and
it took me three years
to get wings.
This was back when we had
a lot of budget cutbacks,
so it took awhile to get
through the training program.
So by the time it was
all said and done,
I could finally get out,
it was 10 years anyway.
So I was weighing, OK, do I
stay in another 10 and retire,
or do I get out?
And there were a few
things about the military
I did not like.
I think having grown
up in the military,
I was so used to being
told where to go and live
and what to do.
And I was like, I want to
go live in San Francisco.
And I want to go
live here or there.
And I want to travel
whenever I want to.
I wanted more
control over my life.
That was really the main reason.
Secondary to that was, in
the Navy, if I stayed in,
the jobs I would be doing would
be more desk jobs, more staff
jobs, and I really liked flying.
I really liked being
on the carrier.
I wanted to do
more of that, and I
knew that my options for
doing that were going
to decrease the longer I was in.
And I knew I wanted
to start a family.
So I just have
the utmost respect
for our military
service members who
serve while having children.
And I didn't know
if I could do that.
I had two dogs when
I was in the Navy,
and it was hard
enough leaving them.
I was like, if I can't leave
my four-legged children,
how am I going to leave
two-legged children?
So all those things
came together
and I decided to
leave the service.
CELINE: I'll round out the
talk with the last question
on, based on your experiences,
any learnings that you want
to share with the
group or key takeaways?
LOREE DRAUDE: Yeah.
I think for me, what made
the biggest difference was
leadership in the Navy, and
particularly in our air wing.
We were the first air wing
in the Navy on the West Coast
to deploy, but a few
months before we deployed,
there was an air wing on the
East Coast that deployed.
And they did not have any
of the issues that we had.
A couple of the female
aviators were the top landers--
we call them "Top Hook."
It means that you have some
of the best landing grades.
The women there felt supported.
It was a very different
experience for the women
on-- it was the "Eisenhower."
In our air wing, it was
quite a bit different.
So the first time
we deployed, they
made us all take
a pregnancy test.
So there was this
feeling like they
didn't trust us to be ready.
And there were just
many other things, too.
And so I think having
strong leadership,
that would've made a huge
difference for our deployment
if we'd had better
leadership at the very top.
Like I mentioned before, my
squadron commanding officer
was wonderful, and that make
a huge difference for me.
So I think you really
have to have leaders
who make sure that the
culture supports that change.
And then I would
also say what helped
me was just being empathetic to
the other people I was serving
with and what their
experience must
have been like to have this huge
change really pushed on them.
But then also for me being
put into that situation,
how could we both be
respectful of the concerns
we had about each other.
I was worried that
I wasn't going
to get a fair shake
because I was a woman,
and they were
worried that I wasn't
going to cut it
because I was a woman
and maybe wasn't getting
the training I needed.
So being empathetic.
Then finally, humor.
That got me through a lot.
I think, especially, too,
with carrier aviation,
it's literally life
and death environment.
And I think because of that,
aviators tend to have, I think,
a more wicked sense
of humor about things.
So leadership,
empathy, and humor.
CELINE: Great.
Thank you, Loree, for your time.
Happy Veteran's Day.
[APPLAUSE]